hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive game to share with you from
this is one of the games from Fisher's
famous book my 60 memorable games
he has the white pieces and he's playing
against International Master Hector
Rosetto
Mr Rossetto would go on to become a
grand master not very long after this
game 1960.
and about this game
I know I'll frequently begin a video
saying I have an instructive game to
share with you
this one I feel though is one that
shines much brighter than most
before I hit the record button for a
video where I'm presenting a game like
this
I load the game on my computer I make
several passes through the game using an
engine testing out different lines and I
tried to decide what to share and what
not to share
this time around for me though it was
slightly different
the last pass I made with this game
was done on one of my physical boards
I did this without using an engine and I
did this in silence
and I'm glad I approached it in this way
because
when I made that final pass I ended up
noticing something all of a sudden there
was a pattern that appeared to me about
Fisher's play
and it's this pattern by Fisher that I
feel plays a significant role in the
final position of this game one where
black ends up in zuksvong a position
where regardless of what Black's move is
there will be a significant downside and
this is frequently seen in the form of
material loss
I wonder if you can pick up on what this
pattern is as I play through the game
one final note I really do feel that
this game here has a real chance to
impact your game
I really do feel it has a chance to take
a player who may be a bit on the
impulsive side and help them to become
more disciplined
okay on board we have
an open Sicilian
C4 indicates the maroxy bind grip now
over D5
and from here Bishop D3 computer is a
fan of this move first negating any
lines related to a pin with Bishop to B4
all right though
Knight C6 here
Bishop E3 Knight takes on D4 yeah this
move here reminds me of another note
about this game
um
black never really maintains a piece on
white side of the board
for more than a half move
so we just had a capture on D4 and of
course we're getting the recapture
okay there goes the black piece in
White's house
this happens a handful more times black
never establishes a piece on white side
of the board
okay we continue Bishop C5
this wasn't the uh the main pattern that
stuck out to me about the game though
we continue Bishop C2
White's in a position to recapture on D4
D6 in this position White Castles
the ID to take on C5 is never really a
good idea now that this Pawn is on D6
this would simply be inviting
the black Pond to the fourth Rank and
this Pawn now all of a sudden would
control the weakest Square in White's
Camp D4
we could already start to see variations
where a rook eventually pivots there
okay so in this game it is simply
castles
Bishop D7
Knight A4
he says you take me
black does just that
Queen recapture
Rook d8 now that there isn't a dark
Square Bishop around this can certainly
be sensitive
white now has some pressure on it
black simply castles so you can't win a
pawn in this position
by taking on D6 in the game it's Rook a
to C1
if white takes on D6 we're going to get
Mass exchanges and this Pawn is going to
fall in the end
this is what it would look like
this variation here
after you take like this this guy's up
for grabs
balance material Rook on the open file
not really a line for white to go down
so it is simply Rook a to C1
and now in the game Queen A5 is played
considered best is to knock out the
Knight and only then play Queen A5 to
play this unbalanced minor piece
position
okay
then this one though it is Queen A5
straight away so this guy is hit twice
but white has a nice move here Queen B6
no time to take on A4
so we get this queen Exchange
and with that we go straight from middle
game to end game
okay Bishop C6
this guy's hit twice convenient enough
to defend this guy the king is now also
ready to contribute
Knight D7
let me throw this to you as a pop quiz
how would you respond to this last move
feel free to pause the video
okay in the game best move
Knight D5 so for much of this game it's
even it's even in this position
um how do you get it to a point where
there's still some chance to win how do
you create some imbalance in other words
this is an attempt to do just that we're
gonna have coming up a night for Bishop
exchange as well as a change with the
structure
now
in the game it's Bishop takes Knight
what's the story if the pawn captures
the Knight
how is white recapturing
well this guy has a responsibility to
control the B5 Square
so white would be taking with the E Pawn
in the event of Pawn takes
uh on D5 and white would get the piece
back and be the better side here
especially if this capture is allowed in
the d-pawn is exposed
so black doesn't approach it in that way
he simply captures with the bishop
and now how to recapture White's
recapturing with the E pun now initially
you may think oh you do that so that the
Bishop's eyes are opened up
that is
a reason though I think it's a secondary
reason
there are some cases here
after the reply E5 the bishop
can go to not G5 but rather F5 and be
irritating in some cases but really the
main thing the primary reason behind
this capture is to create an imbalance
with the structure let's now have a look
at the queen side
and what's going on here well we now
have a case of four versus three what
does this mean well with enough prep
work eventually white will be able to
acquire a past pun on the queen side
okay
we see this in action right away in
comes B5 taking away as well uh the C5
Square from the Knight
from here G6
flight Square prep work for F5 as well
alright Bishop A4 is the follow-up
and the reply here is
well let me not share what that is just
yet let me throw this to you as a pop
quiz how would you react to this last
move feel free to pause the video
okay in the game it is B6 considered one
of the the best moves
if you were thinking about playing
Knight B6 in this position let me give
you some tips as to why you shouldn't
approach the position in this way I
could see many players play this move
thinking you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna meet this attacking move with a
counter attack
what's the issue well the issue is white
takes a step back and says my Bishop is
better than your knight my Bishop
controls your knight
and my Bishop doesn't get in the way of
any of my pieces or pawns and your
knight does
the bee Pawn now can't move cannot play
a role in trying to restrict these guys
from moving in particular
you know black is not anywhere closer to
stopping a C5 break
okay in the game it is B6
there's this grip over the C5 Square
from here Rook D3 you'll notice with the
B6 move
A6 is now unprotected this move is a
step in the direction of targeting that
weak point
the reply here
is F5
this is where black starts to go a
little stray
the best move
is A5 anticipating this idea trying to
at least interfere with this idea of
putting the Rook on A3 in what way does
A5 try to interfere with Rook A3 well
you have to do something about B4
white all of a sudden would have this
question
do I try to maintain control over C5
or in other words do I play A3
this would interfere with Rook A3 in
order to maintain B4 so that I maintain
control over the Knight C5 move
what other options would White have
in reply to A5 if you're taking on A5
earlier I just showed a position where
the light Square Bishop would be
preferable to a knight here's a
situation where the Knight would
immediately become
the best piece in the game
hitting the Rook hitting the bishop
and this is not a good position for
white look at that Knight golden Square
on C5 a pawn poison you'd end up in a
pin
what other options would there be after
A5 C5 here's a line that is apparently
going to turn out to be equal we enter
this rook and pawn end game
okay
the game doesn't go in that direction no
A5 instead F5 and now Rook A3 swing the
bat completely around
a blink away now from taking the night
and taking on A6
black apparently has just one chance
left to stay in the game
he doesn't find it
he plays the second best move
in the game the Knight goes to B8
securing that A6 Pawn
what is considered best yet again what's
being suggested here is A5 now in order
to play A5 you have to say to yourself
okay I am fine with
entering a rook and pawn end game down
upon
that's what this continuation turns out
to be after takes takes takes takes
there we are computer says there's still
a fighting chance for a draw here
okay not easy for a human to pull that
continuation off
second best move as it turns out is a
losing move
White NOW gets to create this past Pawn
the minor pieces still stay on board if
it's just the Rooks greater chance that
you could hold the draw but
this guy is superior to the knight in
this end game more Pawn exchanges is
good news for the long range piece
so C5 B takes C
B takes C
D takes C Rook takes C this guy was
poisoned all the while
there would be a pin and win of The Rook
if it was ever captured
from here King G7 Rook B3
Rook F7 now that this guy is on the
seventh rank this one is tied down to
defending the Knight so white can now
push the past Pawn
no Rook takes Pawn because of Rook takes
Knight
Knight D7
Rook C7 it was under Fire
Knight f8
and from here Rook B7 taking the Rook is
just going to be helping the king he's
not moving forward but he's moving in
the direction he wants to go to
approaching this Pawn black needs to
track this guy down but by playing Rook
B7 two pigs on the seventh rank here
this is forcing black to
capture on C7 white recaptures with the
pawn and is now a blink away from
promoting with discovered check
only one way to stop that
Rook C8
and now only one winning move here I
wonder if you can spot it
feel free to pause the video
okay winning move is
Bishop B3 cutting out 96 if this Knight
could get here this Pawn is going to
fall
so now black is in quite the predicament
what do you do to improve your position
these next handful of moves the
remaining moves here by both sides are
just pawn moves and we get to a point
where all their advances have been
exhausted and we get to this sucks phone
position
what's the issue with moving any of the
black pieces
well if we look at the black Rook can't
take the pawn of course it's defended
any move along the eighth rank allows
promotion with check
any night move let's say to D7 would
allow Bishop E6 and there's a problem
here
Black's gonna have to give up material
very soon
and
the last note what do you do with the
King
any king move would leave some defense
of the night so for instance the most
logical looking move
ing in this direction trying to track
this guy down this would now be met with
Rook B8
what are you doing here
The Rook takes Pawn
that's the best you could do and then
you're gonna lose the Knight
it's just a little bonus there to do it
with the check
completely winning so black is now in
this giant knot he cannot move any
pieces he has to move pawns but they're
easily just going to run out of gas A5
met with A4
H6 H3 G5 G4 chop
one more chop that right there
is the ball game black throws in the
towel
what do you do any pawn move you're just
going to lose material and we already
had a look at all other
piece moves
what is the pattern
in this game that I feel
has played a significant role
that played a significant role in this
final position let's have a look at this
bishop it's a third ranked Bishop
look at The Rook it's a seventh rank
Rook look at the pawn a seventh ranked
pun
look at the black pieces ranks one and
two black is on his back foot
there were nine cases in this game of a
capture
recapture sequence
and you know what in each of those cases
Fisher was never the one to initiate the
capture
he was always the one to recapture he
was the king of the recapture in this
game
when you're recapturing you are
after the pieces have been traded you
are
improving your piece very often you're
improving by a couple ranks if I take
just a
a quick skim through this game right
there if the Knight has improved a rank
on the recapture right here improved
slightly with the bishop when the queen
recaptures she's improving three ranks
he does this time and time again the
night is improving there on the
recapture
it continues nine cases of this in the
game once C5 is in capture recapture
capture recapture and even we when we
get to the seventh rank here he's not
initiating the capture he's taking this
you capture me approach capture
recapture and black in the end
is in this
phone position it's not always going to
happen like this but I think that this
is an excellent game that highlights
that strategy in the game it's okay to
not initiate the capture
very often this can be beneficial and I
think this is highlighted very well with
this one game this idea here this is a
subject i t uh I covered in the one
video uh on in my beginner to chess
master playlist video number 28 this
stop before you chop uh approach
anyhow I hope covering this video in
this particular way was helpful for you
I hope it was more memorable for you
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below hope you enjoyed it maybe
took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
thank you